breaking overnight a mass shooting in
Germany has left at least six people
dead authorities say the gunman then
killed himself armed police arrived
shortly after gunfire was reported at a
Jehovah's Witness Meeting Hall in
Hamburg Germany's second largest city
Holly Williams is monitoring the latest
developments Holly good morning
good morning at a press conference in
the last hour German officials confirmed
that the shooter was a 35 year old man
they say he was a former member of the
Jehovah's Witness congregation that he
targeted and had no criminal record
this cell phone video appears to show
the shooting in progress
with several bursts of gunfire inside
the Jehovah's Witness Hall there was
reportedly a Bible study session but we
still don't know why that was the target
[Music]
German police sealed off the area and
armed officers stormed the building
survivors were evacuated and searched
the police now say the shooter acted
alone and was one of those found dead
there were probably 25 shots at least
and after the police got there there was
no gunfire for a long time said this
witness then after five minutes or so
there was a single shot
I saw seriously injured people dead
people wrapped up in bags said this man
it was very hard to see mass shootings
are rare here in Europe where gun
ownership laws are much stricter than in
the U.S that only makes this deadly
Rampage more shocking
German officials say the gunman had a
sport shooting license to carry the
pistol he used police also say they'd
previously received an anonymous letter
warning them that the shooter may have
undiagnosed mental health issues Tony
all right Holly thank you very much